we sent our own raymond arroyo on the
road to scranton pennsylvania to find
out what
folks in joe biden's birthplace thought
of the debate tonight
raymond held a focus group at the hilton
downtown
uh scranton hotel and the conference
center there and raymond
tell us what you found
laura look here's what we did we got a
group of three
undecided voters two trump supporters
two biden supporters
and i'll tease it this way there was a
convert
in the course of this debate we took on
the issues
as they came forward watch he wants to
shut down
this country and i want to keep it open
and we did a great job wait a minute let
me shut you down for a second joe just
for one second
we want to he wants to shut down the
country we just went through it we had
to because we didn't know anything about
the disease
governor he has everything everything
held
yeah he oh my gosh i oh
you could just bust like i think he's
just so wrong about that
and then he's talking about the deaths
of coven are you kidding me
look at all the democrat governors that
put all these people in the nursing
homes
that how many numbers are is that like
come on when he talks about scranton i
think of
um my sister she's she worked as a
waitress and she's raising a
four-year-old daughter
the hardest thing for her was having to
take care of her child while still going
to work every day and when things shut
down she didn't know what to do
if it comes to a point where the country
needs to be
or certain areas need to be more locked
down i think that that
if it's the responsible thing to do to
save
lives i think that that's okay you're
never going to have zero risk
in anything i get in the car i'm driving
on the highway of a higher chance of
dying
than i do in we have to have community
policing like we had before
where the officers get to know the
people in the communities
that's when crime went down it didn't go
up
it went down and so we have to be in
this is not what they're talking about
chris
who do you have name one group that
supports you name one group that came
out and supported you
go ahead i think we have time we don't
have time to do anything
well i know biden has said he didn't use
the word defund
but it meant the same thing and i don't
think trump has ever said that donald
trump does not want to defund the police
he wants to take care of them but
make things right but needs help what
they need help with
get the help that they need and but
i don't think joe biden that's not where
his head is at
i don't want to see two white males up
on stage
fighting back and forth about race and
defending the police because i mean it
doesn't affect them
so i think that going forward you need
to have they don't have a plan they
we we need to go forward have a plan we
should be spending more money on
um making police
you know giving police the tools to deal
with situations
in a more appropriate way
so laura that was some of the back and
forth during the debate then we have the
post debate
wrap up watch as some of these
undecideds grappled
with what they saw and we've had at
least one person
flip but i won't tell you to whom watch
i'm
undecided about joe biden based upon the
local democrats and who i
who i encounter the local democrats are
determining how i'm viewing him
if the local democrats are treating me
this way i can only imagine how
joe biden's going to treat me once they
complete
uh the the entire uh dictatorship that
they got going on and as far as donald
trump is concerned
the only way that i'm going to vote for
donald trump or or even consider voting
for donald trump
is if donald trump understands one thing
he has to be quiet
about matters of race he has no clue
what it takes for me to be a black man
living in america
did this debate change
any of your view of these candidates
raise your hand if it did
oh really okay hold on let's go to bill
bill it changed your opinion why well it
because i've become
less enchanted with both of them
i was kind of open and hoping to hear
something
that was going to change my mind and i'm
just
disgusted by i mean it's just i didn't
see
any respect on either side
when when trump was interrupting biden
constantly
when biden turned around and said you
clown
to the president of the united states if
a foreigner had done that
we'd be up in arms it's just i've
again i had little respect for him i
have less now
for both of them both of them so you're
still undecided i'm still undecided by
again my
i was hoping that i was going to see
some change today we have two more
debates
and and if they can make their case and
then
they will but i've i still don't like
either one of them let me go to my other
undecided john did this change the math
at all for you
not a whole lot if i had to vote
tomorrow based on this it would be tough
um i'm going to say if i had to vote
tomorrow i would vote for
for um our current president um based
on when joe biden talks
it's very hard for him to say what he's
a solution for something
um and he just attacks attacks now
donald trump does the same thing
however i think he right you know
watching this and then
the last four years and they've had four
years to come up with a solution against
donald trump
and they have not done it who of the
candidates
had more passion more gusto more
vivacity
i've always believed it is that
candidate who eventually
wins the race uh who thought joe biden
had that vivacity that energy
that passion one
conor's half in okay who thought trump
okay so the majority of you thought
trump had that you didn't put your hand
up to him
you didn't think he you were on the
fence why not i've been at a few rallies
and the excitement it's like
wow tonight i don't know
i don't know what was he missing tonight
he was not on offense i mean he was he
was trying to
uh counteract what biden was saying
but he wasn't making his case the way he
does
probably at one of his rallies i've
never been to one abigail did joe biden
do what he needed to do tonight
i think he did i think the humor needs
to be on twitter
not not on a presidential debate um
i think that like i said in the
beginning i was here to hear solutions
and um not the humor so the nastiness
didn't
offend you tonight it didn't offend me
now okay connor
did it offend you some of the nasty
exchanges
i think that there are a whole lot of
important issues going on in america
and i think that two guys fighting
on tv isn't going to change any of them
there has never been since he was sworn
in as president
an ounce of respect for that president
from the media
from anybody on the on the left it's
just
there's just no respect and i think he
has to fight that
every day and and this is
this is why he comes off sometimes like
he does if you had to say who won this
debate
who would you say donald trump show of
hands
joe biden show of hands
so it's 2-2 i have abstainers here
i have abstainers so it's a it's a tie
with the
with the with a couple of abstentions
thank you all for your honesty your
candor and for being with us tonight
laura this was quite a mixed bag tonight
it was
it was many of them thought this was a
runaway debate
there was no clear winner and they
turned off a lot of undecideds
because of the nastiness calling the
president a clown
but everybody has to get their answer
sharper and the the moderation of the
debate
also was uh a question and something
that many of the people here raised
hmm well i i i have to say
the idea of being undecided i never got
that raymond
i mean if you don't know by now what
trump's economic record is
what open borders and locking you down
next year is going to do
i don't know how to explain it to you i
i that i i
i just don't get that at all but it was
very impressive that you have more in
the days ahead
and the ingram angle team turned that
around so fast i know how hard that is
to do
and kudos to the producers and for you
raymond thank you so much it was really
interesting to see it